Yeah. Long story, right? Yeah.
I definitely drank too much
coffee before we get here.
So if I appear like cracked out, I
swear to God I'm not in pills, but uh,
glad to hear it. But, um,
so we had a nice conversation on the
phone about d platforming and social media
and, um, what did,
what was very obvious to me in talking
to you was that your way more schooled on
this than I am.
So that's why I wanted to have this
conversation with you because part of what
was like, I really listened to
my podcast with Jack and, um,
you had a good criticism of it. I agree
with a lot of what you said. First of all,
I agree that it was kind of boring
and it was, I think in many,
for many reasons it was my fault.
Uh,
I don't think I prepared enough for it.
And I also don't think I understood the
magnitude of how other people felt about
d platforming on Twitter
and a and all social media,
youtube and all these different things
and what the ramifications are and how,
how much this means to people
to have very clear and obvious,
obvious free speech outside of very
egregious examples of like threats and
doxing and things like that. Which
I think we can all agree, right.
I think this problem
that might be one of the,
like one of the worst problems we're
facing right now politically. Yes.
You know that Twitter is where
public discourse is happening.
It's where journalists are and this is a
problem sourcing a lot of their stories.
Yes. So if you have somebody
who is completely removed
from public discourse that
that's exile, you know, I can't,
I can imagine why some people kind of
lose their minds and that happens. And um,
I think going into that
conversation with him, well,
that's what I wanted it to be.
That's why I don't really
interview people any kind of,
have conversations with them. Occasionally
we have disagreements and we, you know,
we talk about things and you know,
but it's not, I don't have, uh,
uh, like a mandate. My only con,
the only thing I wanted to get out of
the conversation is I wanted to find out
what it was like to start
that organization and to
have no idea when you were
doing it that it was going to be
essentially like one of the most important
distribution at a re avenues for
information and act and act as buddy of an
activist.
A buddy of mine asked me if I knew why
people smash windows smashed Starbucks.
It's not because they think
they're going to cause damage.
It's because they want to strike a symbol
down of something they view oppresses
them. Jack Dorsey is that symbol
to a lot of people and you know,
to see you're here.
You know what I was saying earlier is
I think a lot of people look at you,
you're like a real dude. You know, your,
your conversations are real. You have,
you're not one of these
fake news journalists that
people are very critical of
that field.
They're biased or have an agenda.
So when you sit down with Jack
Dorsey and doesn't go anywhere,
people then feel like the last person
who's not supposed to let us down,
let us down. You know what I mean? No,
I look, I thought you twice as much.
I've felt it and I noticed that I got,
you know,
more hate for that one than probably
anything that I've ever done. And uh,
you know, I'm not a guy who
shies away from criticism.
I try to figure out what I did wrong
and try to regroup and figure out how to
approach it again. And in
Jack's defense, uh, you know,
I think he's very open to
talking about anything.
And also he's also very open
for self criticism. I mean,
he was openly discussing what they're
doing wrong, where they need to be clear,
where the navy to get better. I
don't believe any of it, you know,
I don't trust that guy. Not at all.
Um, you know, why don't you trust him?
I mean,
first of all,
there's the obvious thing that he's
running these a bunch of companies.
I could be wrong,
but I believe he actually left Twitter.
He wasn't the CEO for a while.
They brought him back in or something.
But it either sounds should
probably check on that.
I tried to avoid asserting things
that I'm not 100% sure on, but me too.
But I do it all the time anyway. Right.
Jack says things like, he said to you,
he said to Congress, I believe
he said, he said to Congress, um,
we don't ban people based on the content.
We ban people based on their conduct.
Yes. Okay. You, you,
you literally have a terms of
service that band specific content.
Like what do you mean you don't make it
based on content? There's a, you know,
I'll just get into naming some people.
Right? Megan Murphy for example,
as a feminine, Megan Murphy,
is she okay. She's that woman.
That was the whole issue with
women. Right, right. So, so here,
this is what's important. She
was responding to somebody.
Explain that for you.
So this could be standalone, cause we
talked about it yesterday with Sam Harris,
but um, so I don't know too
much about Megan Murphy, but
she's a feminist. She's a,
what they call a trans
exclusionary radical feminist.
But I think that that might be offensive.
Says let's remember why Jack Dorsey was
fired as Twitter CEO. He was fired. Okay.
We'll see what it says.
This,
this is in fortune 2008 that was there
wasn't even what sort of Twitter?
Yeah, yeah. 2008. Jesus Christ. Um,
Dorsey's management was so problematic.
Twitter's board, this is an opinion piece.
Fired him in 2008 offering him a passive
chairman role and silent board seat.
2010 he was founding square.
Square. He went rogue. Okay,
so something happened. You know, it's
funny as you called it, an opinion piece,
but do they, I dunno, that's, that's
where we're at in journalism today. Well,
when someone said,
well,
it has to be an opinion piece when someone
says was so problematic. Right. I mean,
that's an opinion. I mean, sure. The
real facts are, he was fired. You know,
you could state the specific reason
that was stated by the company and that
would be a non opinion piece. But as
soon as you flavor it, it's all opinion,
right? It is, right. Yeah. That is a,
that is an issue, right? With information,
the distribution of information.
It's flavored by opinion
in ideology. All of it.
Yeah. All of it. Well, we can
talk about that. I don't want
to derail it. No, no, no.
I don't want to read thing. Yeah. Okay.
So Megan Murphy, please explain it.
She was a feminist. She said
she's a, so she's called.
There are a trans exclusionary, I look,
I understand this is offensive. You know,
I guess calling someone a
trans exclusionary radical
feminist, I'm assuming,
why isn't, why is a offensive, it's
just used in a, in an offensive way,
I suppose to them. To her offensive
against, against people like her. Yeah.
So there's intersectional feminists.
They tend to be trans inclusive,
meaning that they believe that,
uh, someone who born biologically,
biologically male can compete with
those by biologically female if they
transition, if they take
hormones and things like that
can compete, compete, right.
Like power lifting, racing bikes, biking
and stuff. That's where I step in. Yeah.
You know, I've, I've seen some of
the stuff you've talked about, uh,
the Trans exclusionary group think they
shouldn't and they've said things that
are considered to be parked.
I say consider it to be offensive.
I'm not trying to assert who's
offended by it, but um, there's one,
a recent story where a trans exclusive
radical feminists said that the Trans
Rights movement as a men's
rights movement, right.
They say things like that.
In the case of Megan Murphy, she
responded to someone, she said,
men aren't women though.
That's not harassment. Right.
That was a conversation
with somebody else. Well,
it's also a fact she was permanently
banned. Well, that's crazy, right?
That just saying men aren't women. Okay.
Out of context, just say it right there.
Men Aren't women.
Who the fuck's gonna argue with that?
Well then when you say trans people, okay,
now you're into gray area, but actually,
but the statement men aren't women. Well
you didn't have to take it in context.
Right, right, right.
But this is where we start getting into
the nitty gritty of I guess left wing
ideologies. The culture war. If you
go on Wikipedia and you look up, man,
it will tell you a man is
an adult human male, right?
But if you look up trans man,
it will say a trans man is amen.
And so the transection of Wikipedia is
at odds factually with the man's section.
So there, there was an, I bring this
up is that when it comes to Twitter,
then we can clearly see the bias.
Twitter says you can't miss gender someone
and that presumably that's why Megan
Murphy was banned. Okay. That's
a left wing ideology. Right.
But that's what she's talking about.
A specific human. I think she was,
I think they were having a
conversation about somebody,
I don't know the full details
details, but I gotta say, look,
right now people are being banned or
suspended for saying learn to code. Okay.
That's, yeah. What is that about?
You explained that to me too
and I saw a few people getting,
but should we start one at a time? Should
we, yeah, let's stick with Megan. Well,
I mean, I think we've, we've, we've,
we've reached that point of Megan, right?
She was banned for having a conversation
and saying men aren't women though.
That was the quote, men who
aren't women though. So,
and they're saying that they would
never ban someone for content.
They banned them for behavior.
Right?
So if we use that behavior that
I have no idea. Like, listen,
if you are using Twitter,
the way Twitter was designed to engage
in respond to people is that bad conduct.
It can't be conduct. It literally
can't be conduct. Not only that,
aren't you allowed to have opinions
that are in fact based in biology?
Yes.
You should be in the,
I shouldn't have out before we go any
further before you get called alt right.
You, you're very left.
Right. Um, I, I, you know,
I typically say center left
center like, uh, Oh God.
People were saying how many
times someone commented,
how many times will Tim mentioned he's
a social liberal. Lying I'm center left.
Uh, I was a big fan of Bernie,
you know, Bernie Sanders,
he's still one of my favorite politicians.
Uh, people that call me a socialist,
you know, conservatives call me
left, left, calls me right. You know,
these labels are so fucking toxic.
It's so confusing to people and it,
and it causes so much,
so much division between two sides.
It might not even differ that much.
You know,
the funny thing about it is I got my
start during occupy Wall Street and
conservatives called me far left
because I was reporting on the protests,
what they were doing, police
brutality, the arrests.
They said this is a far left activists.
Now that I'm,
I've always been critical of
the more extreme factions.
Like I've got interviews
from seven, you know, six,
seven years ago where I'm
critical of these people.
Now all of a sudden they're accusing me
of being alt right for being critical of
extremists and masks, you know, starting
fires and things like that. All right.
Adjacent. That's my new favorite
boot licker outright at Jason.
We'll boot licker boot licker
that's, that's, you know,
there's a lot of phrases that people use
that mean literally nothing boot Lifton
um, one, one of my favorites is
to keep in the context of Twitter,
they say freedom of speech,
freedom of speech does not
mean freedom from consequence.
That literally doesn't mean anything.
It literally means nothing. Yeah,
well that's just trying to skirt around
freedom of speech. That's what it is.
So what ends up happening,
but, but you agree with that,
like you should be able
to speak your mind,
but there's certain consequences
of certain things that you say.
If I throw this bottle at the wall,
there's a consequence.
So that's a physical move motion.
If I drink this water,
there's a consequence I to go the
bathroom rights. So to set to,
to point out that actions
have consequences,
not actually addressing any of the issues.
It's just literally saying nothing.
But it's, it's, it's
almost, it's just like a,
you can predict when someone will say it
and it's usually when a specific person
is band, they'll say freedom of speech,
freedom of consequence, all that stuff.
They don't say it went to their
people. They say, yeah, but,
but this is true too in talking
about Twitter censorship.
There are people on the left
who have been banned on justly,
and this is where it gets actually
scarier in my opinion. You'll have,
I could name so many people, Jesse,
Jesse Kelly was banned for no reason.
Cj Pearson was bad,
I think to why you say no reason what?
Now they have no recourse. I
was an accident. Oops. They
said it was an accident.
Yeah. Then for life or band, he was where
he was a short amount of time. No, I,
so I could be wrong. Um, my understanding
is Jesse Kelly, who's was a conservative,
had his account just band and there was
a huge stink in the media. Like, Whoa,
Whoa, this guy didn't do anything. Who
is Jesse? Kevin's a conservative guy.
You know, he, he, he posted snarky tweets.
He doesn't harass people or
anything's a verified Twitter user.
So a bunch of stories came up saying,
what,
what is this Twitter then reinstates
and said it was a, it wasn't,
it was a mistake.
Now is it possible that
they're just dealing with
blunt tools and that there was
a mistake or, well, yeah,
absolutely. Absolutely. Um,
but then I'd have to,
they're,
the reason why I don't think it was
a mistake very simply. As for one,
we can see the ideological
bent to their rules,
but then you look at someone like Milo
Yiannopoulos, like I'm not a fan of Milo.
I have to make sure,
like everybody knows that,
but just because I'm critical of
the actions taken against them,
it doesn't mean I support him, but why
was he banned? Because he tweeted it.
Leslie Jones.
Right.
And the idea was that his tweet
caused his fans to attack her,
which I think is, that's a stretch.
That's, that's, that's just,
that's just ridiculous. He didn't say
go getter. He didn't say attacker.
He was just tweeting at her. Yeah. And
you know, what did you call her ugly?
Did he say something like that?
He was insulting or he,
I think he called her aglow.
He was mocking this feminist
version of Ghostbusters.
Right? That's what he was
doing. He was talking,
it was like a critique of the movie.
Look,
I've had milo in the podcast way
back in the day. I had them on twice.
I enjoy talking to him. He's hilarious.
He's very smart. He's very witty.
He's a character. He's very
much a provocateur. Right.
But he's also, you know,
he's pushing buttons on purpose.
Like he's trying to get reactions from
people and trolling. Yeah. I mean,
I almost think like he married a black
guy. Just let people know he's not gay.
Oh yeah. Let people know brother. He's
not racist. It's hilarious in that way.
I wouldn't, I would never say something
like that, but I almost think it,
you know what I mean? We can understand
why my would do that. He's calculated.
Right, right. Yeah. But he
did that. I don't think he
did that. It should be clear,
but I mean that's how much of an act.
A lot of what's going.
But if you talk to him off camera,
he's a very nice guy. Very reasonable,
very polite. I don't, I don't trust them.
I'm not, I'm not a big fan. You know, he,
he fat, shamed to do it at the gym. Right.
There literally is a picture of you while
making a ton of photo of a guy at the
gym, the gym. And I actually argue with
them about it. At one point I was like,
you won, you won your skin and he's
fat. But no, you, you can leave.
You literally shamed him to the point
where you decide to go to the gym to
better himself and you're still making
fun of them. So did he, wait a minute,
he shamed him before the guy went to
the gym. I mean, I don't mean literally,
I mean like Milo's rhetoric of shaming
people and getting them, you know,
saying they're,
they're nasty and stuff and then it
right back down with the guy listened to
them and that's why he went to the gym.
No, no, no. I didn't mean literally.
I just mean like if Milo plays it up,
like I'm going to shame people until
they don't work out. Why would you? But,
but I'll say this, look, that's fine.
Milo can can say the nasty things
and be the kind of person he is.
He shouldn't have been banned
from Twitter. That's ridiculous.
Why was this verification badge
removed? That was another. It's, it's,
it's plain as day. The verification
one was weird. It's like,
we're going to keep you here,
but we're going to take away
the verification lets people
know you're you. Right.
So it opens the door to fraud. Right.
And it opens the door to fake my lows.
And you don't know who's who
because there's no blue check mark.
That doesn't necessarily make any sense.